he is none other than Melvin Ingram back
here in the Rich Eisen show how you been
Melvin you there Melvin he's talking to
Gus Radley okay just trying to make
those two up okay commanding him the
phone right wait Bradley there Bradley
rivers and Ingram right now have a nice
little powwow are they really in the
middle oh hey Melvin you there okay
we're on we're on the air live I don't
mean to bust up you're talking to your
DC and Phillip Rivers is that what you
were doing right there yeah yeah we have
a little friendly conversation okay what
were you talking about anything I saw my
football just on my football they try
and put me a running back and
quarterback you know so I had to get it
straightened mighty coordinator person
what would you what would your play be
if you were at quarterback Melvin I'm
probably go 5 wide so you'd spread out
the defense is what you're saying yeah
I'm gonna spread it out in five wide out
fight over speaker I'm on it
okay no I understood well I don't know
if you saw you know Mohamed Sanu you
know he threw a touchdown pass to Julio
Jones you could do that right yeah my
blood Mohammed six for six right now
well quarterback gonna leave right now
yes that's right through the roof now
but en+ you could move around better
than Phillip right I mean I'm I'm a
magician in that Park mmm have you ever
have you ever thrown a pass at any part
of your career anywhere yeah yeah
definitely high school high school
what'd you do yeah so I was doing I I
started off going a quarterback Oh God
come on now yeah you first you first
started playing quarterback Melbourne
Ingram the 88 first variety hunter of
quarterbacks in the National Football
League um started out playing
quarterback these boys I went out of
quarterback challenges right here mm-hmm
I love it all right so let's get into
the let's get into the mix here here for
for the Los Angeles chargers uh before
we get to your current game your current
status I want to come back to this
because I'm come I'm calling you from
inside AT&T Stadium where you spent
Thanksgiving against the Dallas Cowboys
now what did you see in the Dallas
Cowboys that you you thought you and
Bose and everybody else could exploit
Melvin
we really don't see what we see and then
we know we got enough and we feel like
it looks like going against anybody
really can explore some some weakness in
some way and that's what we try to do we
we just work hard every week and try to
study our opponent but we know what we
have in our room and and we know where
that we can explore something okay
now that sounded like a highroad comment
to me I'll be very honest with the
moment
it ain't a hard rule common is their
confidence in in our room we know we
know the work we put in and we know
everything we've been through together
well then help me out and the rest of
the national media out and certainly
those here in the Dallas Metroplex area
because the the talk is is that the
Cowboys offense is so vanilla or their
offensive scheme doesn't have much many
wrinkles to it that defenses know what
play they're gonna run based on down
distance tendency formation in a way
that they they they wouldn't be so easy
to figure out for other teams how would
you assess that theory Melvin that's
right every option has got some
tendencies right there just like because
he's playing men in certain situations
they like to wear a certain place that
they feel work
so going from films 32 to really
breaking all that down you really find
that out about every office got some of
those tendencies no matter what office
or who you clean again so Dallas isn't
is simpler to figure out as anybody
else's with you know I won't fade out
it's just an open book I definitely
would say that ok very good
now what about the Cleveland team that
you're seeing on film a very talented
team that's what I see are great
Football Club yep that played hard no
matter what just looking at everything
that I've been through in the last
couple of years and see the way they
play is crate like they play lights out
for four quarters no matter what and I
just feel like they did you think had
some of the breaks you know some of the
breaks to win some of those close games
and we don't been do I share those too
so so we we we're approaching this just
like every other game man so it's a
great game I feel like it's gonna be a
great great game on Sunday is gonna be a
hard fall game
and we're gonna try to come out of the
win the end of that you're not just
trying to talk up an opponent with zero
losses no I'm wonderful fit telling the
truth okay you're seeing that on film so
how is this team different from the the
team that started on four and went into
MetLife and got their first win and have
only lost a couple of times since uh we
start making those plays in the end
that's the thing it was we we restored
really making the plays and count at the
end of the game cuz I and every football
game is a couple little plays that
determine the outcome of the game and
where you can make those big plays in
those big time situation you can control
the outcome and again I feel like we're
gonna start making them okay and are you
aware that the Chargers bandwagon is
filling up fast are you where that uh no
I really ended it I'm into the people in
this locker so the thing is if you start
getting caught up in that stuff you'll
be you'll be somewhere you don't want
because when it was going bad everybody
said nobody was with us and I'm not
sitting here once saying it's going good
right now so I really don't know what
was going on with the bandwagon thing
I'm just I'm just robbed for being in
this locker
what's your relationship with those are
like uh we got a great relationship like
a younger brother too we we talk every
day we grind together every day we've
got a great relationship I mean what are
you talking about everything really life
football everything what life
what LA but what part of life d'etat
guys don't think Bose has kids I know
you have I know you were dad but just
know just just everyday life just just
just what normal people talk about the
same stuff you talk about with the
people that that's around you and that
in that stadium you got some friends in
that a child just have general
conversations about life ain't nothing
in particular is just okay
just be a friend well I talk about how
much I love the University of Michigan I
know BOSU when you talk to me about that
I know I probably wouldn't but he would
probably say you love Ohio State though
then I will be a general Cartwright you
had a know a big conversation ender for
me that's the then I would just have to
walk away
what do you think about what the Giants
have done with Eli Manning Melvin I know
it's not wrong but I'm sure you heard
did I
but me I'd say I think Eli's is one of
the best quarterbacks that ever played
in his League really
and and the number of things he's done
in New York is its countless so so I
think it's just more of a respect factor
I think I think I think it should have
been handled a different way me but
that's that's really above my paygrade I
don't really know how to decision go or
none of that but just from the outside
looking in I don't know I don't know I'm
seeing your paygrade
that's that's not a bad pay grade I
don't know how much is above that pay
grade Melvin and I guess I would get the
same answer from a giant pass rusher
about Eli in the same way that you might
feel about Phillip right I mean what are
you her I know you just left a
conversation with Phillip but what what
walk me through about how the team feels
about their guy who was drafted in the
same draft glasses Eli Manning no oh
wait wheels we put the house on our guy
I got he's one of the best to do it to
their experience know coverages and
everything no the officers like the back
of him and and that's what we're going
to war with no matter what because it -
that's the leader of our franchise
really that's what that's where our
franchise got as our leader and we got a
great whenever leader on and off the
field really would you would you ever
wear one of his bolo ties oh yeah
definitely definitely
do you want to meet you are definitely
wrong hmm is that part it would that be
your your style as well Norman yeah
definitely I'm um I'm a fashion
statement so I really can wear anything
is that right how do you come to the
stadium she come dress I come what are
you I come looking a maid I come looking
amazing any kind of a la legitamate like
what I mean because we don't sometimes
see you you play in the late afternoons
usually so we don't usually show charges
arriving in the stadium no we're not
we're a different things yeah I wear
everyday whatever come to my date when I
wake up I never plan ahead to wear some
I just I got I'm just a real stylist and
my my face and my soul when I wake up I
just put an amazing outfit for you okay
because at anytime we see somebody
looking sharp
Earvin or fog will say they they know
they're gonna win today would you agree
with that sort of a system definitely
loads on cheap labor they pray good how
did you come dressed to this stadium
than on Thanksgiving I came looking
amazing really the stadium is that what
you're saying
come on I have like a white collar shirt
with some blue blue a red pants with the
white and red shoes
that does sound amazing all right well I
didn't mean to take you away from your
conversation with your coordinator and
with with Philip so go back but I really
enjoy our chats next one's got to be in
person in Los Angeles okay Mel yeah
you're definitely okay you got it that's
moment English you got it the Los
Angeles chargers so Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience